let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
welcome everybody this is the tony
michaels and this is gabe sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the tony michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the week
welcome back
to the show thanks for sticking around
to the break we have a special guest
with us stand up comedian the host and
head writer of emmy nominated game show
idiot test he also had his first hour
stand up special neuronic gangster on
showtime he's a star of chelsea lately
tbs
called him one of the funniest comedians
working today he's also an anchor for
the young turks where he also does his
own video series for rebel hq three
times a week and his second
hour special drops
uh it actually dropped yesterday on
helium comedy youtube page go check it
out welcome ben glebe thanks ben for
joining us here on the tony michaels
podcast how have you been my friend i've
been great especially pleased now that
you nailed that intro and you were so
insecure about it i know well it was a
it was a big intro i was a little
nervous because as my audience knows i
completely [ __ ] up intros gabe knows
this my audience knows this so that's
like the first one i think gabe is that
the first one i really had a slam dunk
on yeah no no hiccups along the way that
we know of on camera yeah i'm not going
to point out the two hiccups there
actually were because it was so close to
being right right right well there are a
couple mentioned that i was one of the
stars of chelsea lately because the show
hasn't been on the air in about a while
that is fears or the fact that it's
helium comedy studios presenting the
special i wouldn't mention though
because he did such a good job tony on
the rest of it well you know i'm glad
you mentioned those though that way the
audience knows exactly
the the history of chelsea lately and
that it must you must go to the helium
studios com whatever you whatever the
actual name go to wherever just search
the mad king on youtube there you go my
name
is that's it hey that brings me to a
point because you sent me an advanced
copy of this special and it's great
everyone should go watch it it's
hilarious um it doesn't just have
political and social issues which is
kind of the issues i want to talk to you
about today um but
what who are the mad ones what is that
what what's the mad ones i want to ask
you about that real quick absolutely
yeah thank you for watching and for the
kind words um the mad ones are my fans
across the globe um
it
it's a name really that kind of took
shape during the pandemic when i when we
were all shut down and i created nowhere
comedy which is the world's first
virtual comedy venue and became the best
and we created this community and i
started doing this with this weekly show
at the time now i do it about once a
month called glebe off the top crowd
work and improvised madness and the
people that i attended regularly with my
were my die hard fans and i called them
i started calling them the mad ones
after the kerouac quote the only people
for me are the mad ones yeah i got you
and they started calling me the mad king
and which is part of why the specials
called that and these amazing group of
people that attend
most of the shows i do online they
travel around north america to see my
shows live i mean
some of my fans have come and seen me
just in the last year or two in the same
people in dc
vancouver
uh indianapolis
dallas they just travel around
philly where i tape the special and
they're amazing um and so i wanted to
shout them out in the special quite a
bit as far as just giving them some some
homage and some love
and uh
so that that's the mad ones
well we we love our fans here too
they're called the [ __ ] fans so i
know [ __ ] em fam so i know i know you
know [ __ ] them [ __ ] you even [ __ ] up
that intro yeah that's yeah well yeah
and have i [ __ ] up every intro i told
you i told you this is a thing that
happens here on the tony michael's
budget nice this special though
you mentioned one of my
all-time favorite charlie kirk pieces of
content that you are in you it is it is
a very famous piece of content i
actually think gabe we've probably
played it on our podcast i don't know
three or four times i [ __ ] hate
charlotte
it is definitely an evergreen type of uh
piece of content
i love that yeah i hope that clip never
leaves him it's the dolphin fetus clip
it it is the dolphin fetus clip and i
think people have have watched it i'm
going to show it again here um really
quick because i just i just want people
to remember exactly what the what the
clip is but
i i have a few questions about this clip
and the reason why is because we've had
another friend of the show rachel
bittikoffer went and she went to debate
night or whatever that i think that's
yeah that's what he calls the debate
with charlie kirk he she went and
debated him and she sent me the footage
and i was like hmm that's kind of funny
and here's the reason why i have a
question because i wonder did he
intentionally send you this footage that
you were able to
you know make into a clip or is this
part of he actually put this in that
debate night like he put it in
well listen i'm a very strong negotiator
it's part of being the mad king is not
taking not letting other people set your
terms and so uh when he reached out to
me you know he famously reached out to
congressman eric swalwell
and he offered him to be on debate night
and swalwell instead put his dm on blast
and said i'm not going to go and debate
an insurrectionist that makes me and my
family unsafe
i instead accepted the exact same dm
that charlie slid into mine with
and said i'm gonna go debate an
insurrectionist and humiliate them
and
do what i can to make sure this person
is weakened
because they are an enemy of the people
anybody that
that supports turning over an obviously
fair election
and did so by sending buses of people
there and encouraging them to fight
uh deserves to be
taken down and you know
there are people that even don't want
this special to be
heard i was telling you guys off air but
i don't care i'll announce it on there
my facebook page was as was was hacked
taken away from me stolen got recovered
last night and was just stolen again
this morning there are forces that don't
want you to see this special and
we cannot let them i will not let them
i've worked too hard for this
and um we need to get you know some of
the truth and keeping these idiots these
male intended [ __ ] honest and so
not that my special is going to do you
know going to change anything on the
grand scheme but we all need to be
talking speaking our truth and speaking
truth to power as much as we can and
every little bit counts um so i
negotiated very strongly with charlie's
people that they had to allow me to
shoot my own
iphone footage of the whole debate oh
wow so this so this actual this clip
came from your iphone
so what you're saying is is charlie did
cut this out of no version no i also
made them promise that i would not do it
unless they agreed to cut out zero
content unless there was just
dead air and so they had to agree to
that in writing
and they did and so um they released it
but what they did do sneakily at the end
of the debate in the bonus time
um
they did cut out the bonus time where i
then call him out on funding the
insurrection attempt and the protests at
the ellipse or rather the approach loops
that led to the insurrection and i got
him to storm off of his own show and
storm off of his own set did you ever
shoot you so they cut that they cut that
out i that's on my full debate on
myyoutube.combeegleeb
you can see the whole debate's an hour
20 it's the extra 15 minutes that we do
that shows that happen and because i
released it and released a separate meme
showing that and so he was forced to
then show it he then uploaded a second
version of the whole debate that did
include that so he could pretend like he
didn't cut it out right he definitely
did cut it out because both versions are
still live and the second version he
called me so-called comedian as the
title
put me on your show bro what does that
speak to your own booking ability if
you're so-called but my favorite part of
the charlie kirk negotiations not only
did i get all those details set so that
i knew i would be protected and that i
could post all these clips much as i
want but i further got them to agree to
fly me out to a studio in arizona put me
up in a dope hotel give me a car service
and pay for all of my meals when i was
there so right after i was kicked out of
his studio and security escorted me off
after i made charlie run like a baby off
of his own set i still had a car service
the rest of the day i just wait take me
and my girlfriend now fiance to a very
nice sushi restaurant arizona and we had
a 270 sushi dinner on charlotte
oh my god did you know i thought i
thought i thought that this dolphin
fetus piece of content was the best
piece of content but right now in this
moment that story that you're telling is
a damn good piece of charlie kerr
conference you realize that the mad king
strikes again
what's that i said the mad king strikes
again that's right man and and aside
from that one meme too if you don't want
to watch the whole debate we released on
my instagram as a little christmas gift
to everybody during the holidays last
year 12 days of kirk's and ass and
every day we released a new meme where i
own him from that debate all the topic
of abortion a great topic for the
holidays isn't it oh absolutely well i'd
like to get into the uh abortion
abortion um
subject nobody's getting into my uterus
you understand that
let's let's watch let's watch the uh the
famous
charlie kirk getting schooled on
abortion in 15 seconds
do you truly in your heart of hearts
truly believe that this is a human being
this without a doubt without a doubt yes
this is a dolphin fetus
without a doubt a dolphin fetus is a
human being this is a human
but
quite different dolphins you just
confirmed that a dolphin in in life you
confuse dolphins for human babies often
so let me go to sea world and you're
like somebody's got human babies in that
aquarium ben
did you have this whole thing prepared
and you knew you were going to strike or
you do you just carry a little
brown bag full of uh dolphins
pictures in your i usually do carry a
brown bag of dolphin fetuses that's just
my sexual kink it's the only way i can
come but
um i happened to bring it to this
location because i had that moment
planned i knew exactly how i wanted to
phrase it i knew exactly how i wanted to
give him fairly a chance to say yes or
no that he believed that was a a human
or not i wasn't trying to trap him but i
had an exact way to phrase it where i
said to him
i showed the i plan to show the photo to
the audience and then to him and say do
you and your heart of hearts believe and
he said yes i gave him an out i said
i
i said you do or whatever i said i give
i said do you believe in your heart of
hearts this is a human being and he goes
without a doubt and i go without a doubt
i give him a chance
he could have doubted at that moment
i think so i can't tell the photo right
he goes yes
absolutely and so i talk about it in my
special as well um and a little bit of
of of the behind the scenes of that um
because uh he is a
bad person yeah i just love the stare
off to whoever whoever was on set or the
producer or cameraman was like oh [ __ ]
yes yes that'll haunt him forever and um
when i was in arizona my now fiance um
didn't understand why i needed to stop
on the way to i had to have the car
service drop us off on the way to the
set at an office max or office depot or
whatever i'm like i got to print this
photo she's like who cares gets a whole
debate you've been preparing for two
weeks i'm like i need this dolphin photo
picture trust me did anyone have a story
40 million views across platforms
and it went as big as possible did
anyone at the store as you as you were
printing it out did they stop and go
huh okay yeah i mean they they looked a
little weird thank god
they knew it was a joke it's not
pro-life yes they knew for sure
thank god that dude was was not a kirk
supporter in phoenix arizona you do
never know um but also it was another
fun part of that day was it was the
greatest um
debate prep vibe i've ever had um before
a serious moment like that because my
fiance loves lazy rivers and the hotel
they put us up at the arizona grand
resort has like some huge lazy river
around the whole resort it's a water
park
and so i wanted to i was studying for
weeks i was being you know advised by
narrow and planned parenthood
unofficially unofficially people that
worked there um were giving me advice
and uh
and i still have more research to do so
we literally were in a lazy river and i
was on my phone researching abortion
rights and talking points and
counterpoints and she was holding onto
my tube from her tube and just every 10
minutes that she was relaxed and maxed
out as could be i'd be like babe do you
mind looking up the 13th amendment 14th
amendment can you give me the full
language of that hey look look up for me
real quick dobbs if you can with the
full language of dobbs and she's telling
me about abortion details i'm putting
into my brain while little children who
were not aborted were floating by
very unaborted uh
fetuses inside these tubes that were in
the lazy river my favorite kind of kids
are non-aborted kids oh really okay well
that's good that's good
so
so the special is great and you release
two clips on instagram and the one
actually is what caused me to go hey i
need i need to get a hold of this guy i
love the charlie kirk 15 seconds dolphin
fetus abortion video that is a fantastic
piece of content i gotta ask him how he
got that piece of con or how he got that
video from charlie kirk now we know now
we know that there was another camera in
the room but i want to play first this
is hilarious the the airplane uh clip
you put on instagram of your special
let's play that real quick how can we
can never get the volume of the
announcements right on airplanes
we've had aviation for decades no one's
told this to the airlines
always the
announcements are far too loud or far
too quiet
and the important ones are far too quiet
and the dumb ones are far too loud
the captain of this vessel gets on he's
always like
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sorry did you say engine fire
and then five minutes later a flight
attendant comes on we're gonna be coming
down the aisle with the united mile
blaster car we're gonna give you 50 000
bonus miles
can you use that speaker for the death
announcement
because i'm sitting here sucking my own
and i don't know what's next
so so ben clearly yeah you do just a
little more than political and social
comedy obviously um which i think that's
a hilarious clip thank you
so tell us about the special though
because i've watched it but how long did
it take you to work through this
material because it's a full hour a
whole hour how long did it take me to
write that stuff i mean basically this
is the material that i've been
developing since my last special and
it's been some time because of this
weird
slow moving business so uh my last
special dropped in 2016. so it's been
about
six years
in the making of developing this new
stuff and um
it's the best pulled out of multiple
hours of stuff i've been touring with
these last handful of years and i just
you know talk about
a very wide range of things in this
special like you said i talk about i
mean just as like as a quick rundown of
some topics i talk about
um
lgbtq rights and
bathroom protests i talk about national
anthem protest i do a whole long chunk
on religion on the constitution i talk
about the me too movement i make fun of
wokeness i also
make fun of
um
i make fun of girls that are too into
mermaids i tell stories about extra
girls
i the girls that want to be mermaids i
talk about um some stories about
ex-girlfriends and things they did that
were strange weird dates i had weird
proclivities of mine fights i've been in
therapy stories about me discovering
that i had adhd and being in therapy um
just our crumbling planet living in a
post-truth era bias racism i cover all
these different things technology robots
taking over and just some weird stories
about me and my girlfriend uh being very
lazy humans and overeating on the couch
we cover it all in this special and so
i've been developing the material for a
long time and i jam-packed in a lot of
stuff like not to talk [ __ ] about other
comedians but just to talk a little bit
of [ __ ] the most special that i watch
these days
it's an hour of like very long stories
that
you might get four stories in an hour
you might laugh three or four times in
the whole hour special if that from some
of the greats even people are considered
the greats
and i hope watching this special you're
gonna get like 30 topics in an hour and
four minutes it's more than an hour and
i think you're gonna laugh 50 plus times
if not 100 times i'm hoping to keep you
rolling for an hour plus and this is a
different experience i think
well it was absolutely hilarious and i
love that you did walk through all those
topics um and you did it so well one of
those topics being religion
and really right now in our country we
have sitting congress people
a woman in georgia specifically who
claims that she is a self-proclaimed
christian white nationalist or whatever
she's saying i mean it's it feels like
she's saying she's a nazi but i want to
play a clip here before we get into that
too deep uh that also was on instagram
where you talk about uh god jesus and
bumper stickers let's listen to this yes
indeed because people get so hung up on
labels you see everywhere bumper
stickers that say like jesus is god read
the bible
and whether or not you believe jesus god
it's just kind of ridiculous to cite as
backup proof
the only place that says he's god
that's like saying animals can talk
watch doctor doolittle
oh
that that you know that reminds me
almost of the charlie kirk slam dunk
with the with dolphin fetus there
when you're when you're going after
people with the bumper sticker well it's
because because what i try to do i i try
to create moments that corner people in
like in in
perfect logic that can't disprove how
are you going to disprove that clip
there is no disproof to that it is a
perfect analogy you can believe jesus
god if you want and i say in the special
i respect all people this is a a special
i think that is both progressive and
crazy as [ __ ] you can be both it's not a
mold that many have figured out but i
figured it out you can be extreme and be
funny and say crazy things while also
not being cruel to people so people
should have whatever religious beliefs
they want ever gives them comfort but
put an asterisk on it like i say in the
special we think we're pretty poor but
to cite as oh it's this is fact it's in
the bible yeah that's the one place that
says it that's the book that says it
that's like exactly like saying
animals can talk because of dr doolittle
because she watched the movie yeah right
right i don't remember who played him
eddie murphy or steve martin one of the
two i'm pretty sure but they're not god
do you understand the point they're
right right well getting very riled up
because i am the mad king there's many
uh definitions of mad i'm partially
wacky and weird i'm also partially very
angry i'm also very very sleep deprived
i'm on three hours sleep right now i was
working on artwork for the special and
editing an animated intro for it until
nine am this morning oh wow i'll recover
now my identity before we started this
podcast so
i'm i'm very mad in many ways well so
let's let's talk about that anger and
let's direct it in in a way that we can
talk about this white christian
nationalism because we watch
over the weekend um
this last weekend we saw cpac on the
banner and i think they did it as kind
of a joke
but they announced to the entire room we
are all domestic terrorists and they
they had it on the jumbotron as if it
was some kind of dig on liberals or
something and i was like you're you're
now branding yourselves as domestic
terrorists and that's what it feels like
when marjorie taylor green and some of
these other politicians are embracing
not just their christianity right but
they're saying you have to be christian
it is a christian nation and you have to
do these things and you have to think
the way i think or else and that's
that's the way it's starting to feel do
you get that sense a hundred percent i
mean lauren bober went as far as a week
or two ago saying that the government is
not supposed to dictate
how religions operate which they're not
but religions are supposed to dictate
how the government operates which is not
at all true that's a christian
nationalist a fundamentalist [ __ ]
opinion it's inaccurate and it's them
openly and overtly saying we only care
if you're white christians that is it a
marginal retailer green saying the same
thing this should be a christian
nationalist nation that it should not be
and you should get the [ __ ] out of this
nation if you believe that it is let
alone serve in the halls of power of
this nation right let alone being
someone that also supported and winked
at these interactions very strongly for
weeks leading up to it including the day
before and i think the day of as well i
mean these are horrible idiots that clip
i'm sure you're referring to partially
here at cpac of marjorie taylor green in
a jail cell fake
yeah crouched down praying with brandon
strzok
the also insurrectionist who served jail
time for it and who i also have
destroyed in a debate on my youtube
uh where i took on at the same time him
and tommy laron and aaron elmore in a
video on my youtube page called ben
glebe systematically destroys fox news
talking points
where i took all three of them on at
once
and
destroyed them on every single point and
i do play-by-play commentary in this
video how i destroyed them and i bounced
off the show and tore off my mic and
stormed off at once i hit the peak level
of their ignorance and racism and cold
heartlessness enough these people do not
have a place in our government they
don't have a place in our country the
only people who should go back to where
they came from is the people that
believe other people should go back to
where they came from people who think
that who pushed that should get back on
the [ __ ] mayflower or whatever white
bred vehicle they came here on and go
back to country of origin and stop being
these isolationist
closed off [ __ ] that try to make
themselves feel better by oppressing
others and try to make people
uh try to make excuses for the fact that
all of their policies only benefit
themselves the very rich the very top
greediest few i talk about that in a
special too by making it seem like these
culture issues they use to divide us
which are complete non-issues also talk
about that in the special are completely
manufactured controversies that they use
to keep us unaware of and unfocused on
the fact that
they don't have policies that help the
average working man they're against
unions they're against time off they're
against paid maternity leave they're
against
better working conditions or against
raising the minimum wage they're against
every single thing that would help
working people but they get you real
riled up about abortion and about
bathrooms and about anthem kneeling
which hurts nobody
and they keep the country divided so i
take all that on the special i have a
bran i have a video that just dropped
the other day on exactly that too on my
rebel hq young turks videos where i just
break down
piece by piece how hannity uh now says
that if you wanna if you're having
trouble making ends meet in this country
just work more work 70 80 90 hours a
week how about instead pay people a
living wage how does that sound right
well that that sounds like logic and it
probably goes against my bad
you would you would think you'd be like
oh that would make more sense if we just
did it this way and they i feel like
republicans are they really push through
the most inefficient ways of doing
something and they go well i don't
really give a [ __ ] what you guys are
doing as long as i'm able to line my
pockets and you know travel how i want
to travel and you know be where i want
to be without any of these constraints
that i want to project onto other people
and they're like oh my life my life is
great i'm good to go you know which is
exactly what you're talking about these
republicans will project their own
insecurities their own ego problems
everything onto other people to
to limit access
and limit the rights that they have
within their own lives and it's and most
of it's not even genuine it's not even
their own insecurities it's it's things
they realize are wedge issues they don't
care about those things they've all had
abortions they've all paid for abortions
all of these
rich
unfaithful right-wing
congress people they're mostly horrible
hypocrites
and
they just do it for wedge issue and it
affects their own life they don't
believe a damn thing that they say well
you know that brings up a good issue
before we we head out here is the
hypocrisy and we we it's been a great
week for democracy the last few weeks we
the the primary in kansas where
overwhelmingly the people in kansas said
no you're not going to take away our
[ __ ] rights that's not going to be a
thing that's going to happen you can go
[ __ ] yourselves even in a red state like
kansas you also we also watched the the
raid of donald trump whatever that may
come of that and then the i and i think
the best part of the raid honestly if i
was a woman i would have been made very
wet by that
so so you would have you had
that brings up another character didn't
make me hard because that would have
been i would have been a little weird
like it wasn't sexual for me so i'm just
projecting on to a part of the
population that i can't relate to but
i'm assuming if i was a woman that would
have turned me on i don't know you don't
know well i mean it happens that way but
i get i guess where i was getting hit
that that the raid more than anything
because it's important like what happens
and the crimes that he committed but be
a little hard probably right a little
just like a little chub you're just a
little you know
but the thing the thing that i think is
most important is the reaction of the
right wing media that was the most
important thing about the rate not the
rate i mean the rate is probably
important itself like in history because
it's never happened before but in this
moment in the in the body of
where we are politically right and this
back and forth like you're saying the
hypocrisy and they're full of [ __ ] and
they don't actually believe this stuff
it's just the tail wagging the dog type
[ __ ] but the actual reaction from the
right wing because they were freaking
the [ __ ] out last night and tonight so
much so that tucker carlson charlie
kirk's older brother couldn't even
appear on his show last night he had
some wish.com tucker fill in for him on
fox news but the reaction was so
beautiful but really i think it's so
important and it really speaks to how
their back is against the wall because i
actually think that's the biggest fraud
that donald trump has wrought on our
country is that somehow there's this big
support for him and trumpism and all
this nonsense
well i think there is a big support you
don't think there's big support
well i actually think that it is a big
it is a large number of people but it's
a small percentage of our country and i
think a lot of it is that some people
need permission to say yeah okay i don't
actually believe in all that stuff i
just say it because it's it's like i say
all the time we're at the intersection
of wrestlemania and real life and a lot
of these people have made politics
they're wrestlemania right it's the it's
the saturday night thing that they do
that they pretend and they go to work
and oh you gotta like this and you gotta
like that second amendment and abortion
and but they don't really understand the
inner workings of what is happening i
when roe v wade was overturned by dobbs
i said soon there are gonna be trumped
up white dudes that walk into a gas
station in a red state looking for
condoms and the clerk's going to go we
don't have [ __ ] condoms what do you
mean you don't have condoms well we
don't have condoms because you vote for
republicans and they ban condoms because
they don't like for you to do the things
that they want to do right and so that
realization that hey this affects you as
much as it affects
the woman that you don't want to have an
abortion right i actually believe that
there is a large
number of these quote unquote trump
supporters that aren't actually trump
supporters it's a go along to get along
thing it's i like the evil villain
because he feels good to me to like the
evil villain in this moment and i think
i think until we get to a situation
where we can make the evil ones i'm
talking about the bad ones the ones that
want to commit violence they want to
overturn our government they want they
do not want us to be a democracy because
it is a threat to their fascism until we
get them to crawl back underneath the
rock and they do not have permission to
do that kind of [ __ ] anymore we're still
going to have this trouble in this
country where this fraud
of trumpism
is is really rotting our country right
now i see what you mean yeah i totally
agree with that i do agree it's a very
small percentage of people that actually
understand what they're espousing right
i really believe that absolutely i think
it's a sadly enormous percentage
probably 30 to 40 percent of the country
that goes along with it that has been
tricked if they follow one of three
categories they truly believe it and
they're evil people or they are very
dumb very very very gullible
and have been
hypnotized by you can't blame them to
some degree by a party and a media
ecosystem on the right that has
convinced them that
everything that is on the other side is
against them is fake is false is
cheating is taking away their rights is
making their life worse just raising
their taxes even though it's the exact
opposite
and
the other
section are people that are just kind of
nerdwells they're people that are just
not great folks that are like oh let me
root for the villain even though it's
real life i mean to some degree you
can't give them that much slack because
yeah they might not fully understand it
but they're aware that they're cheering
for a president who's acting like a like
he's a bad guy in wrestling they're it's
not roddy roddy roddy piper up there
he's the president and he's talking
about real lives he had them cheering
the other day i did a video about this
rebel hq he goes you all know biden the
deaths under biden were way worse than
my deaths and they go whoa
i mean he got a cheerline on a mount of
american deaths being more under one
than the other
which is like physically accurate of
willingness to account for all the
factors that trump [ __ ] up but even if
it was accurate he has
you're cheering
for american death instead of being like
whoa i'm leaving this arena right now
because this is a pale
far too far and so
yes i don't know how we put it back in i
don't know how we how we think we need
some sort of truth
we need some sort of truth
uh some some unbiased bipartisan
of the people truth commission we need
to enforce
uh truth and advertising laws again
truth and broadcasting laws again we
need to make sure we do not allow people
to call themselves news that are just
blatant propaganda machines not based on
facts there are things we can do
but until we figure that out we have to
just you know make noise we have to make
it known we have to mock the people that
are trying to execute this we need to
laugh at them and uh
i think my special's a pretty good way
to do some of that well that that's
great what because me and gabe me and
dave are talking about exactly the topic
that you're saying is comedy dead is
satire dead is parody dead because these
people really make it difficult right
man you know to level up from where
they're at to get the satire and the
parody like even even the moment at cpac
where you've got you know marger taylor
green in a jail cell like that would
totally outside of the fact that people
kept tagging me and they thought that i
was the guy in the jail cell doing event
and i was like that is that is not me
i'm i'm not him
but the the fact that that people were
like oh yeah gabe would totally do this
in a video or this would totally be a
bit
means that like have we jumped the shark
here like are we just making like
real life making fun of itself like what
is the republican party is
non-stop you know 100 if they're not if
they're not doing one crazy uh drinking
their piss for covid they're doing
something else where you'd be like
this would be something you would make
fun of and they're like nope this is 100
genuine and you're like
what the [ __ ] is going on well they
gotta own the libs you know that right
yeah a lot of this like it's it's again
it's a wrestling match you gotta get
your your chair on the back thing but i
i well they're they're very sad that
slavery's over so they feel like they
have to own somebody
well that that is one way of putting it
ben i i think i think you're a warrior
in this fight i think the the the just
the videos that you put out just the
simple one of charlie kirk owning him
and mocking him like you said and just
exposing him for the fraud that he
really is um is is is moving the needle
and i agree with you i think we have to
continue to do this stuff to move the
needle to eventually get shame the ones
who are dangerous to crawl back
underneath the rock to wake up some of
the ones that are just kind of
hypnotized by this all like you said
100 i couldn't agree more thank you guys
for doing your part in that fight as
well tell us one more time it dropped
yesterday but tell us one more time
exactly where to go so i don't [ __ ] it
up tell us where exactly where to go to
find your special your second one-hour
special tell us exactly where to go so
also easiest way in some ways is just
follow me on instagram or tick tock i
post five videos a week there are other
stand-up videos excuse me crowd work
where i make fun of the crowd uh
highlights of my rebel hq videos and my
link in bio on both my instagram and
twitter my instagram twitter is at ben
gleb b-e-n-g-l-e-i-b
the top link will be check out my new
hour special the mad king click that
it'll take you right to it or just go on
youtube helium comedy studios page
search for ben glebe the mad king or
probably just searching for that without
the studios we'll probably bring it up
ben glebe the mad king watch it sit down
with some popcorn and some beer or some
weed or some whatever maybe hard
cocktails whatever you do
flavored seltzer water if that's your
poison you know whatever you need but uh
get ready for uh for a pretty in intense
comedy ride i think
well ben thank you very much for joining
us and don't be afraid to come back my
friend we'd love to talk i would love it
any time we love laughing and we love
talking politics and we love we
absolutely love
dogging on charlie kirk it's one of my
favorite pastimes one of my favorite
thank you very much my friend you have a
good one everyone stick around we will
be right back
right after this break are you thinking
about running for president
it that's a decision that i'm going to
make in the in the coming months
savannah i'm not going to make any
announcements here this morning but uh
but it is something that i i'm thinking
about and i'll make a decision uh in the
coming months she definitely is running
for president that is the entire point
of what i was trying to make yesterday
is it doesn't matter she wins or she
loses here liz cheney is not going away
neither are neither is dick cheney darth
vader junior i mean the good die young
dick cheney will live forever i mean
he'll be at least 565 years old before
he's dead i mean if you go by the the
good die young thing
liz janey loses her primary
to i think someone said wish.com carrie
lake i'm not sure who said it but um
they're about right this is only to the
detriment of the trump caucus in the
house if this person shall win the
general election this is not good for
wyoming it's only good for liz cheney if
you want to know the honest truth here
it's only good for liz cheney it only
gives her a national platform
to launch a presidential campaign bid to
absolutely try to destroy trumpism
because at this point i believe
that trump has miscalculated
on who and what liz cheney is liz cheney
is a very vindictive person she will
come after trump and trumpism and anyone
who supports trump it is very obvious
and she is signaling that she's going to
run for president hell she said the
other day
not in so many words this is my phrasing
of it
she told ron desantis to [ __ ] off yeah
[ __ ] off he's not gonna be the [ __ ]
presidential nominee [ __ ] that guy she
obviously believes that she has a chance
to run and win
now rather she actually does from now
until the time of a republican primary
in this country maybe maybe she does
maybe she doesn't i mean i think it's
hard to tell at this point what the hell
is going to what the political landscape
is going to look like
now some in the republican party
definitely
are betting on that trumpism will live
through 2023
some are definitely betting on that i
think it's a really
shitty bet that trumpism is going to be
popular across the land i think there's
trump fatigue here in certain parts of
the country even in red parts of the
country we see it with the beto aurora
campaign people have trump fatigue hell
they're showing up in maga hats having
beto sign the hats
and so and they support beto of course
of course the mood is changing in our
country how could it not be we have not
just
people who voted for trump in 16 but in
2020 who absolutely walked away from him
because of what he did on january 6 and
now we find out that the guy has not
just
tried to overthrow our government but
he's he's broken the espionage act
taking classified documents the thing
they [ __ ] the thing they [ __ ] used
as the crutch to run in 2016 with the
email lady and then in 2020 that joe
biden just couldn't handle being
president and this guy walks out with
all kinds of documents and you can't get
the story straight this is a great
narrative for liz cheney you've been
listening to the tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking